as hope for finding survivors fades the
blame game intensifies officials
initially pointed the finger at the EU
accusing it of limiting funding for
infrastructure fast the focus of
criticism is now shifting to autostrada
the company responsible for the bridge
locals say they're long been concerns
about its upkeep sorry I buy when we
drive on this motorway and it's full of
traffic we automatically try to go over
at fast
touchwood and crossed fingers we go over
at fast hoping it doesn't come and
crashing down autostrada insists it's
maintenance checks were up to date but
that hasn't stopped ministers
threatening fines calling for
resignations and promising to revoke is
operating license
they include italy's new populist
interior minister entire chunks of
highway cannot collapse like this and
people cannot die like this in 2018 I
want to stress once again that those
responsible will be found out Matteo
Savini has hit out at the EU and the
company that manages this stretch of the
motorway behind me but for many people
here anger and blame will only go so far
they want to know what happens next
crucially how this young government
plans to prevent a tragedy like this
from happening again the blame game
that's playing out here is doing little
to help those suffering the consequences
of this catastrophe they include the
hundreds of residents who've been
evacuated from this area it's feared
that part of the bridge still standing
may yet come crashing down
Carmelo works nearby he says authorities
have given him no indication when he'll
be able to return
palma de una city mana if we talk about
a week it's still sustainable so that
the area is not accessible for a month
then there's a huge problem there are
hundreds of people who have to go to
work there meanwhile the rest of Italy
is watching in horror as this crisis
unfolds the disasters raise serious
questions about the safety of Italy's
roads and bridges with many asking if
this can happen here where's next